you see it after a game often regardless
of outcome dying you see it during a
game when someone's feeding that's not
toxic
I believe no many points up 23 and
sometimes you see it purely as a form of
disrespect gge
well I know what if it's giggy's get
their portable authority if you wouldn't
you gotta win with class GG stands for
good game an exercise of sportsmanship
shared between opponents for as long as
people have been able to compete against
one another but that simplistic
definition doesn't even come close to
explaining all the ways that gamers use
the term today Gigi's origin isn't
completely clear but it appears to have
been first used by gamers in mid to late
90s titles that featured multiplayer and
in that original context it maintained
its meaning as a digital handshake
between competitors sometimes with the
inclusion of WP on the end for well
played the term saw casual usage but it
was in StarCraft that it took on a whole
new level of importance as blizzards RTS
became an absolute sensation in Korea GG
grew and when typed in competitive play
it meant that the player was conceding
the match but since that was true it
also became an iconic point at the end
of every match which the commentators
ceased for their own
[Applause]
there's even a GG button kicking around
the office that we've had to limit do
not [__] press that button again
[Music]
mother that doesn't mean the GG was
always done appropriately though in
Starcraft 2 Greg Edra Fields was
notorious for pushing the limits of
sportsmanship but he also let his
emotions get the best of him at times
leaving completely winnable pro games
sometimes with an abrupt gg
[Applause]
but more often not see you later in
response to this awful but especially
pretty bad they disguise miss Cheerilee
yeah that guy was just awful
that guy was trash that's really bad
this guy sucks in Korea using gg before
leaving a pro match was basically
mandatory and anything else was seen as
poor manners and of course if entered
it's signified surrender which was
actually incorporated into the rules for
Kasper freely but GG has become so
ubiquitous that it's developed all sorts
of variations before matchmaking systems
became commonplace GG know redeveloped
it meant good game no rematch with the
implication being you're not worth my
time GG no that said GG no re isn't as
popular as it once was mainly because a
lot of games are no longer 1v1 and most
have matchmaking systems that decide
whether or not there will be a read wait
I didn't mean it like that man wait what
did you just send me frog re went an or
me touch him
because of matchmaking the path to
victory can sometimes be entirely out of
one's hands and in these situations when
a teammate is really dragging everyone
else down the ironic use of GG as a
flame enters the picture but in terms of
throwing shade one of the most popular
versions of gg in current use is GG easy
[Music]
GG easy is basically a great way to take
a parting shot at your opponent by
saying gg but then adding easy to say
actually you blow
[Music]
common variations of GG ez include ez
game ez life and easy-peasy pirate are
don't we [__] river
Boyd are the rubble BBQ Jesus no Archie
GCM that magazines online Mikasa and
while postgame toxicity is a proud
tradition in competitive games some of
the newer eSports titles aren't playing
ball in overwatch the use of GG easy
reached a fever pitch to the point where
Blizzard took action after August 2016
if you type it in chat you get any
number of supposedly embarrassing
phrases instead honestly I wasn't a fan
of banning GG easy because I'm kind of
an [__] honestly I wasn't a fan of
seeing GG easy but banning it seems a
bit excessive
I mean what's competition without a
little bit of friendly banter [__]
[__] you up
[Music]
[Applause]
perhaps the worst thing about these
variations is that increasingly it
becomes harder to determine when a
player genuinely means good game going
on he might not even have time to grab
his stop he goes down and it looks like
Wow invoker rage quit why and if every
game is a good game is any game really
good no but GG but GG have incorporated
so many variations that it is wholly
ubiquitous in the kingdom is that how
people from your island speak I don't I
like on your bike you [__] wanker